in this capsule we will see an example
which will allow us to see maybe
a little more precisely what we want
say that
the analysis ps the different types
of environment and maybe give
the more concrete example of the context in
which an agent will have to make
calculations and make decisions
in fact we will see an example that when
even very very simple it's taken from the
section 7.12 you books norvig russell and
is sailing so that's what they call
the world says yes and more we can see
it's a bit like a game
of adventurous where one does the environment where
it exists and where in addition that are
creatures that could devour our
agent another agent him what he has to
to make our player is to go
pick up when they are in a
kind of dungeons in which comes
among others holes in which
money could fall
so if we do a worse analysis of
this application the man the measure of
badens performance that if we are going to land
as the provides among others we will
measure very high performance if they
have managed to pick up the cinor a
very low measure at least 1000 if I am
for example raffle the same box as the
one piece or falling into a hole
we will also have a penalty of
less hours per hp not for
basically have a motivation l
encouragement to fetch gold the
faster then get out of the dungeon
with the man and our agent or even a
arrow
and then we go social nation a
penalty if we decide to kill the web
you know that or finally to try to
kill the one piece fully note the ofs
environment note what will contain
among other things it's the stench that can
come from adjacent charms where in
more breezes that they will come from
adjacent charm where can be perceived
in adjacent morning fields where
found pits where the holes
when we will be in the box
associates then we will rather perceive a
flicker obviously needs a
piece that is in the grid and
this one dies if you shoot him an arrow
we have a single arrow we can pick up
lens on is in the same room
and we can get out of the cave if we
found in box 1
ok the starting box in itself is a
description of the different
features of our of our
environment
so that's good because they
sensors in finish have described rather
what types of observations do we
can have a given box one could
perceive a stench or English 600
ch
a breeze or English breaks a
flicker in English twitter jack
so in English apple that would be in the
where we would try to move to
the outside of the grid at long tony
vairelles is a cry that one would perceive
have launched an arrow and that
managed to reach now because
that the shareholders the shares
finally we will be able to take these
turn left to the right
advance grab their climb and
thierry note arrow so that's written
there all aspects of measuring
environment performance title
of observation as ready to see and the
shareholders the actions that can
take in this context for this
agency is to see in the environment
now we could do an analysis
properties with characteristics of
of the environment is it
completely observable not dense that
if we are going to see a perception of
local so it's only when we
found in a crusade jacentes
hole to one more than we will perceive that
there is possibly a more rom to the box
adjacent see a hole as appropriate
is it deterministic of huy
the effect of each action in this case
will be predictable he postpones
of randomness is it episodic
no clearly we will move from
sequentially in the environment
so our action has a given time for
influence the state of the environment
plan too soon we will find ourselves in the
rate as following is what these
statistics static sorry yes we're going
arise in that if our
environment is such that the one piece
and the fake ones do not move the fake ones
also obviously the us group or if the
game set so that they could
to assume that they are not moving
it's discreet yes we could list
all the grids possible every
possible configurations of environment
and the number of actions is over is this
that it's a single agent yes so the
selection actually the world can be done
it is who can devour us on the head
his room so in fact we can
consider as part of
the environment
a bit like we can fall into the hole
if we move in a box that he
contains too much ok so that's
the application where it sinks a
analysis of all characteristics
the properties of the environment in
this context and finally but actually
what are we going to do a species of have done
a kind of simulation of the agent that
would move in our environment
to maybe see a little more
precisely in what context is this
that our agents us different types
agents will have reasoned then act
in a typical environment so in
this case we start our agent
starts at box 1 1 and here we have the
forgiveness perception here we would have a
perception in this case we perceive
absolutely nothing no observation
so our agent in his internal memory
could conclude that this case is ok
in his studio not since
of one piece same thing here and here
since we have no perception associated with
which will bring us though a well or a
rom more in adjacent squares
so following his ready so take
an action choose to go in honor
choose to go to the top right
our chosen to go upstairs and there we have
like watching a breeze and at
from this observation one can
so have to maintain the uncertainty on
the presence of the well either at the top or at
right because if we're not in
able to determine but our agent
could remember that he
there is possibly and then at the top or at
right
then the jump our agent could
decide to move to the other cause
who was associated in our memories
alcohol hockey and when we watch at
this box is a stent so the
stench of one piece while should
to make joy in this case bath a
agent who would be able to do the
logical reasoning could actually
come to the conclusion that there is
necessarily one then to 7 4 6 and 1 8
thumb this time and this is because
that if there had been and then here we have
felt a breeze that was not the case
and if we had a web more here in
did we feel the stench we would have
eu is here what was not the case
so we can update our
estimate of the environment then
conclude that there is a well here full
boom more here is among others we can
so conclude that this lens and
this hold this is ok do not have any
cooking and their notation could
determine to decide to move
here in which he observes absolutely
nothing so
we can conclude that up and to the right
the cases are ok and then the aja could
decide when to move to
right which in fact tend our
knowledge equivalent to parents
preferably from that and when
observe is among others the booth of
we can obviously because we
just find in top of seven cases if we
is observed a breeze also what
leads us to believe that there is
possibly a well here or here is by
against crucially we also observe
of flicker of the and so at this
target time the agent will pick up
their and go back to the starting square
to get out of the cave
so obviously I have not described
of algorithms I presented a
reasoning described in natural language
ultimately is what we will see in the
short finally yielded algorithm allows
to do this type of reasoning there and
several other facts we will see
really a lot of other apps
than just logical reasoning
but I hope this example has allowed
to perhaps clarify a little more what
kind of environment in which we
might have to develop agents
and then what kind of network our calculation
it's in there people should be in
able to do